attendu depuis de longs mois le projet
de loi en faveur des handicapés et
présentait ce matin l'assemblée
nationale par rené lenoir secrétaire
d'état à l'action sociale avec ce projet
l'amélioration du sort du handicap et
devient une obligation nationale
puisqu'il donne à l'ensemble des
personnes concernées elles sont plus de
2 millions en france un certain nombre
d'avantagés de droit droit à l'éducation
au travail un minimum de ressources est
d'abord la loi prévoit la simplification
de la législation
une modernisation des prises en charge
ainsi toutes les allocations 3 pour les
mineurs 5 pour les adultes fusionneront
en une seule pour les enfants mineures
placées en établissement agréé soins et
éducation seront remboursés à 100% dans
les établissements spécialisés toutes
les dépenses de soins et de réadaptation
liés à l'éducation seront pris en charge
sans considération de ressources de la
famille pour ceux qui ne sont pas placés
la loi prévoit une allocation
d'éducation spéciale de 230 francs qui
pourra être doublée en cas de
prestations coûteuse pour les handicapés
adultes qui ne peuvent travailler cette
loi assure un minimum de ressources
garanties qui libère le handicap et de
la dépendance de ses parents basé sur le
minimum vieillesse actuellement de 6300
francs
les personnes handicapées qui peuvent
travailler en milieu ordinaire seront
payés au niveau du smic environ 12 100
francs en atelier protégé elles auront
droit à 90 % du smic et dans les centres
des deux travaillent 60 à 70 % du smic
pour favoriser l'insertion sociale des
handicapés des aides seront accordées
aux entreprises publiques ou privées
pour l'aménagement de postes de travail
cette loi ne résout pas tous les
problèmes mais c'est une loi qui
marquera un grand progrès social c'est
un progrès j'espère que
le travail de du parlement permettra de
donner à ce projet une dimension encore
supplémentaires et une dimension
nouvelle permettra d'appréhender
le problème des handicapés et en
particulier n'oubliera pas les k ô
combien douloureux de ses rangs
handicapés qui ont besoin à mes yeux de
centre d'accueil et de soins je pense
qu'aussi grâce au travail du parlement
on ira plus loin dans le domaine de la
solidarité on étendra un certain nombre
de mesures etc alors vraiment cette loi
répondre à l attente angoissée des
grands handicapés et de leurs familles